- So, I don't know if you've heard,
but it's almost Christmas.
- [Josh] I have heard, yes.
- What's the Groban household like?
- Well, I mean, I grew up
with just such magical Christmases.
I was very lucky.
My dad comes from a Jewish family,
but when he married my mom,
my mom is so Christmas-y.
She loves putting Santas every.
She's got a collection of Santas
and she loves trees and
and decorations so much
that even if there isn't room,
we'll find a place for a second tree.
(Kelly laughs)
The house growing up smelled
like such a forest that-
- Oh, they're real trees.
- Oh they're real trees, oh yeah, yeah.
- She went deep.
- I think there was a bird
in one of them once.
- Wow.
- Yeah, it's a whole thing, so.
- Like a real bird?
- Oh yeah, yeah, it was
still alive thankfully.
We cut it down, tied it to our car,
drove it home, and then
it was like (cawing).
So.
- Oh my God!
- Yeah, it got out okay.
- But speaking of your childhood home,
and just your childhood in general,
you love to share throwback photos
so here's one.
So give me the backstory
of this little one.
- [Josh] Oh hey!
- [Kelly] What's up, you are
so cute in your short shorts.
- [Josh] Have you done "Who
Wears Short Shorts?" yet
for your karaoke?
- [Kelly] No!
- [Josh] Look at those shorts, I am-
- [Kelly] Those shorts are awesome!
- [Josh] I'm the original Evan Hanson.
Look at that arm.
(Kelly laughs)
I think that is the exact moment I knew
that the arts were for me.
(Kelly laughs)
Yeah, you can see the look on my face.
If you zoom in, you can see
the sadness behind the eyes.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, that's amazing!
- [Josh] I wanna be in a play so bad.
- (laughs) You look adorable!
- [Josh] Oh, thank you, bless your heart.
- And so cute with your little cast.
- Man, little Joshy on
"The Kelly Clarkson Show."
Look at that.
- It's adorable.
We love kid pics.
- Full circle.